hola muy buenas noches ya es de noche
bueno un placer inmenso estar aquí con
ustedes compartir este escenario cuando
de télex me avisaron que se celebraba
aquí en yerba buena y me convocaron yo
quería venderles esta idea del poder
maravilloso que tiene la risa y se me
había ocurrido un montón de ideas que no
la lleve a cabo una de esas era entrar
cual vendedora de tv compra con una caja
envuelta pueden imaginar celosos imagino
muchísimos yo sé me imaginaba la caja
forrada acá con una palabra tapada y
quería contarle los beneficios porque
ellos y quiero que ustedes después de
esta charla elijan quieran y deseen
reírse más entonces pensé voy a buscar
beneficios con los que ya me quieran
comprar la risa
y uno de los grandes beneficios es que
disminuye las consecuencias del estrés
en esta sala coqueteo con el estrés
durante el año pasado o este año si
alguien me dice no le doy el micrófono
ir a la charla
todos todos los conocemos vivimos
coqueteamos día a día con él es parte
casi de nuestra cotidianeidad si digo
estrés y que ya está viendo el producto
pero como soy muy buena vendedora y me
apasiona busque otros beneficios y entre
esos mencionan la oxigenación en sangre
y la mejora del sistema respiratorio y
digestivo dije bombazo ya está pero
pensaba todos estos beneficios ustedes
lo pueden encontrar en cualquier libro
página foros que hable de la temática de
la risa y yo hace 5 años que hago
talleres de risoterapia y pensaba cuando
yo le pregunto a la gente cuando se va
de las sesiones y le digo que te llevas
de este encuentro les puedo jurar que
nunca nunca alguien me dijo siento como
oxigena mi sangre mejor
jamás escuché este otro beneficio que es
divino y es siento como se fortaleció mi
sistema inmunológico
tampoco la escuché si he escuchado más
relacionado el estrés me siento
tranquila y pasó a las siguientes
palabras que escucho me voy liviano
encontré paz
hice una pausa
me encontré con el otro
sentir tranquilidad
alegría he escuchado incluso alegría de
vivir me voy con ganas me voy
cuestionando me muchas cosas a veces
incluso escucho me voy con ganas de
llorar
y es que la risoterapia además de tener
estos beneficios hermosos que son
físicos los primeros que mencioné tienen
muchos beneficios a nivel emocional
somos emociones andantes y es muy
importante lo que hablábamos durante la
tarde de reconocerlas para elegir el
poder de cambiarlas
si yo pienso en estos momentos que mi
función es hacer reír a la gente ustedes
lo pueden creer
porque llegamos a una instancia en que
está facilitadora haga encuentros para
que la gente se ría
eso quería venderles algo que ya les
pertenece
y aquí que pensaba lo siguiente y está
comprobado un niño ríe alrededor de 400
veces por día
cuántas veces cree que ríe un adulto en
promedio
me encantaría decirle 200 pero no
un poquito menos
y es menos de 50 un adulto ri en
promedio 15 veces
y estamos hablando que nuestro
crecimiento hacia la adultez 375 risas
se han perdido
y quise investigar y eso sirve de
investigadora y que hice fui y me senté
en la computadora y puso en el buscador
porque la gente deja de reírse y eso fue
mi gran investigaciones no me digan que
no todos hacemos lo mismo todos vamos al
buscador y adivinen qué
estaba la respuesta y hablaba de dos
factores muy influyentes entre éstos el
cultural
si yo ingresaba al escenario
aspecto de personas adultas ser
irresponsable
si yo ingresaba con mi inglés en tal vez
este año fruncido si vio en la calle a
alguien hablando todo el tiempo por
teléfono ocupado preocupado
tengo la imagen de un adulto seguramente
sí porque hemos instaurado que ser
adultos es ser serios que un adulto no
puede venir por la calle moviéndose
jocosamente y a carcajadas es una
construcción colectiva que hoy tenemos
del adulto y el otro factor que es mucho
más profundo y creo que es nos impacta
absolutamente a todos habla de la
insatisfacción
si yo les pregunto a cada uno de ustedes
si estando plenamente satisfechos con
sus vidas que me respondería
y la realidad es que más del 50% me
diría no
y a qué se debe esta satisfacción esto
puede estar el factor laboral
puede ser el profesional
puede ser que vayamos todo el día
corriendo tras metas objetivos
cumpliendo altísimos niveles de
expectativas que a veces ni siquiera son
nuestras porque en esta vorágine de la
locura que tenemos día a día hasta hemos
perdido el sentido de cuál era nuestro
propósito que era aquello que realmente
deseábamos que nos hace felices que me
hacía conectarme con este ser mío tan
pleno y a todos nos pasa en algún
momento
el tema es que si está adulto va
apesadumbrado con una carga tenso
estresado donde empieza a reflejarlos en
su comportamiento muchas veces en la
salud y es aquí donde viene a surgir
este mágico mundo de la risa
así que yo les voy a proponer algo nos
podemos mover un poquitito quieren
moverse un poquitito muy bien cuando
hablamos de risoterapia no solamente
hablamos del acto de reír también me
conecto conmigo porque porque voy a ser
consciente aquello que muchas veces lo
hago de manera inconsciente como
respirar y así como están en sus lugares
si los voy a invitar a que nos pongamos
un poquito más de frente tal vez con los
dos pies y tos
en el piso
y hacer algo que muchas veces hacemos
sin tomar conciencia vamos a respirar
vamos a hacer una inhalación profunda y
voy a llevar este aire mágico a la pared
voy a hacer
y voy a soltar quiero ver cómo se elevan
los hombros
y voy a soltar un poco
y voy a volver a respirar nuevamente
y voy a volver a soltar los hombros
y ahora les voy a pedir algo muy
chiquitito
quiero que simplemente sonrían que tomen
aire
y como sé que una sonrisa puede ser
genuina cuál es el indicativo para el
cerebro ojitos achinados y pómulos
arriba
yo puedo diferenciar la sonrisa en sus
ojos así que si los invito a sonreír a
ver esas sonrisas estos ojos achinados
esos pómulos arriba así y ahora quiero
que saluden solamente con la mirada a
los compañeros que tienen a cada lado
pero para un lado o para el otro hice
contacto tal vez no tuve toda la tarde y
no lo vi no les pasa eso a veces que
están al lado de alguien y no le conocen
la mirada y ahora vamos a hacer algo muy
chiquitito vamos a tomar aire
y vamos a hacer una hoja pero como casi
susurrando
y ahora voy a hacerle lo mismo a cada
uno de mis compañeros pero mirándolo a
los ojos a ver miro a mi compañero
a otra vez
y realmente están
y usted está haciendo el ridículo y esto
tiene la risoterapia empezamos a
descontracturar nos miren como están
sentados de manera diferente esto tiene
la risa la risa me ha enseñado a que
desdramatiza moss que a veces nos
agobiamos en un pequeño problema o tal
vez atravesamos un gran problema
como a mí me gusta la venta vamos a ir
hablando de las garantías que le puedo
dar con la risoterapia si yo me río de
10 a 15 minutos que puedo generar todos
los beneficios que mencioné
anteriormente respirar mejor circulación
voy a mejorar mi estado de ánimo voy a
conectarme con que si yo me río con qué
emoción estoy conectada con la alegría
la felicidad no voy a conectar
seguramente con la pasión con el coraje
con las ganas y quien no quiere sentirse
así
a alguien no le gusta tener contacto con
estas emociones
y las emociones también se contagian si
yo me siento bien mi entorno se sentirá
mejor que puedo yo elegir
entonces yo sí les puedo dar la garantía
de la risoterapia lo que no les puedo
garantizar con la risoterapia y con
afirmaciones positivas y con vibra alta
que la está de moda no le dijeron vibra
alto sepan que la alegría es una emoción
que vibra alto es que a veces las vidas
les de un sacudón
los cachetes los pisos
y quien nos ha sentido en su momento que
no puede más que es injusto lo que está
pasando y se lo dice a alguien que habla
hace cinco años de risoterapia pero que
los últimos seis meses para hacerle muy
honesta porque ya somos un grupo íntimo
de amigos porque hemos reído juntos ha
llorado más de lo que ha reído
situaciones que nos atraviesan tuve que
perder a mis papás en estos últimos seis
meses duelos profundos y aprendí que hay
una conexión única entre el llanto y la
risa así como a veces nos prohibimos
reírnos también nos limitamos en el
llanto y cada emoción tiene que ser
bienvenida
pero tenía la opción estar ahí en mi
cama [ __ ] bolita comiendo el helado que
mencionaron hace rato y si era un kilo
de helado
disfrutando llorando diciéndome pobre de
mí o simplemente seguir y me encantaría
decirles que de repente me paré al lado
de la cama y dije jo jo ja ja ja ja ja
ja ja ja que con mantra de la risa que
lo pueden practicar pero comencé con
cosas muy chiquititas que fue tomar
conciencia que estaban llorando que
tenía los ojos hinchados que me dolía el
pecho que no me sentía bien y que yo
elegía no sentirme así todos pasamos
situaciones difíciles y pérdida de un
ser querido una enfermedad quedarnos sin
empleo
que no te conteste en el whatsapp cada
uno mide su desgracia
pero es una elección personal y ya casi
les puedo recomendar no es necesario que
ustedes concurran a una sesión de
risoterapia para recuperar estar 375
risas perdidas cómo puedo generar
nuevamente reírme
por lo general me río solo me río con el
otro
me río en compañía entonces voy a
propiciar mejores y mayores se encuentra
con quienes la pasó muy bien puedo ver
vídeos graciosos
todo el mundo ahora está con el teléfono
vivimos pendientes del teléfono lo
vieron de utilidad en vez de dormirme
viendo noticias tan trágicas puedo ver
vídeos graciosos puedo hacer una ronda
de chistes o puedo simplemente pararme
al espejo y ustedes si lo van a hacer
conmigo tomar aire
y comenzamos con la letra jajajajaja
con la letra el eje je je je je je je
quiero escuchar la letra i con la letra
o los pocos poco y simplemente generar
este falso estímulo que mi cerebro no
sabe que es mentira y comenzar a
disfrutar de la risa
no creo o si no sé si la risoterapia
puede transformar el mundo lo que sí
puede lo que sí hizo conmigo fue
transformar mi mundo entonces la
invitación es a que se rían más que
tomen conciencia de la cotidianeidad que
llevan en el día a día y que elijan
reírse que elijan reírse para
transformar su mundo así que ríe y
transforma muchas gracias
[Aplausos]